[Music]  [Applause]  what has happened in the world that  normal now passes as excellence when did  we lower our standards yes we are living  in an environment where people are blind  what you don't see you don't know  out of sight out of mind  something happened today something bad  our husbands aren't coming back  Ronald  [Music]  there's dole a lot of money and now  people want it from us  now the best thing we have going for is  is being who we are  why because no one thinks we have the  balls to pull this off  we from this world got you down on your  knees  but this whole thing goes wrong all my  kids to know that I didn't just sit  there and take it  I did something in this city reap what  you sow let's hope so  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you  you